we start tonight with a Fox News Alert
Joe Biden's weaponized doj is at it
again moments ago they now officially
piled on three more charges against
former president Donald J Trump all
related to the document case in Florida
this includes another count tied to the
willful retention of government
documents well this is not what Joe did
next to the Corvette and at UPenn and at
the beach house in Delaware and at the
Delaware University oh yeah same thing
anyway two counts of obstruction these
additional charges could carry more than
20 years in prison and meanwhile a
maintenance worker they're going after
maintenance workers at Mar-A-Lago was
also charged with obstruction now this
entire case about documents from Trump's
presidency that were apparently stored
at Mar-A-Lago now don't forget president
Trump also facing 34 bogus charges in
New York for allegedly mislabeling
certain documents now it looked most
likely also he will face more bogus
charges in D.C over January 6. he can't
forget about Fulton County Georgia
according to multiple Outlets the
courthouse in Georgia now is erecting
barricades as a trump indictment is
looming there now what we have is Joe
Biden's weaponized Department of Justice
they are going Full Throttle to destroy
Donald Trump and I'm sure of parking
tickets jaywalking spitting on the
sidewalk charges will be added any day
now and as for Joe Biden the complete
opposite is happening as we speak the
doj is taking what is our Extraordinary
Measures to Shield the president and his
crackhead son from a multitude of the
most serious charges that can ever be
made in this case against a president
and that is the Biden bribery and
foreign influence peddling allegations
now Joe Biden himself is also supposedly
under investigation for mishandling
classified material in decades data
dating back to his time in the U.S
Senate his time as VP and storing top
secret classified information in a
variety of locations although his homes
didn't get raided that would include the
garage with the stingray that they say
is never open but is open all the time
that would be his personal library that
would be the UPenn Biden Center and an
office building in D.C and of course no
one has been charged with any crimes in
that case at all does anyone even know
the name of the special counsel involved
in that case how can we never hear about
him or grand juries that he has
impaneled as no rage took place at any
of Joe's homes and just like Hillary
Clinton the case against Biden appears
to be going nowhere so you have Joe
Biden president his Department of
Justice politicized weaponized the FBI
and the doj what does that mean it means
Equal justice and equal application
under the law is currently dead in our
country it it is a sad chapter in
American history and the consequences
and long-term impact on our legal system
is incalculable if you're going to raid
somebody's home for top secret
classified documents in one party you
need to raid the home of the other guy
if you're going to say no reasonable
prosecutor would prosecute in one party
you should say the same for the other
party at the same time we have
underhanded prosecutors with the doj
recently cooking up what is the sweetest
of sweetheart deals for the president's
adult son with no experience Hunter
Biden the crackhead seemingly working
hand in hand with Hunter's attorneys to
keep him out of prison all while
shielding his father the big guy from
any Fallout in spite of what is now a
mountain of evidence that is emerging
yesterday quote he's a private citizen
Hunter Biden rolled up to a courthouse
in a motorcade to collect his slap on
the wrist and it was all you know it was
all going according to plan until that
federal judge seemed to smell a rat and
then started asking serious questions
about hunter's sweetheart deal as Andy
McCarthy put it in his column the fix
was in for Hunter Biden until a hero
judge stepped up now the U.S District
Judge in this case Mary Ellen uh norika
wanted to know the future the true scope
of the deal put on record that the doj's
wink and not agreement with Hunter Biden
fell apart right there in the courtroom
before everybody's eyes and to the
bewilderment of Hunter and his legal
team prosecutors then had to admit in
court that Hunter could still be charged
with future crimes including Federal
violations and was still the subject of
what is an ongoing investigation now
that clearly was not the deal they
believed they struck with prosecutors so
the judge very wisely courageously I saw
what was going on and exposed the real
intention of this so-called deal which
was to prevent Hunter and his dad from
ever being held accountable for the
millions and tens of millions of dollars
that they did in business deals with
foreign countries many of them hostile
regimes to our country for zero
experience from his son at the time who
was addicted to crack or was it really
just access to Joe that they were paying
for what other services was hunter able
to even offer them this was Hunter's get
out of jail free forever card and the
judge stopped at dead in its tracks now
think about this how did Hunter and his
lawyer show up to court yesterday to
accept the plea agreement and not know
that critical fact
you know how did they not know that I
think it's pretty obvious Federal
prosecutors were looking to quietly put
this matter to bed once and for all
without explicitly offering total
blanket immunity to America's most
notorious first son that has no
experience now Biden's doj was playing
politics with a Sly attempt to protect
the president's son forever and the
president himself a tremendous courtesy
that would never ever ever ever be
offered to Republicans especially with
the last name of trump and this is what
I mean when I talk about a two-tiered
system of justice in America this is
what it looks like and this is why the
Judiciary Committee is now investigating
how the FBI under Joe Biden and how his
doj part of his executive branch of
government are politicized and
weaponized this is why half the country
no longer has any faith in our justice
system why should they and by the way
while the doj came short of granting
total immunity to Hunter Biden in the
court of law while the plea deal did
explicitly offer blanket immunity for a
variety of crimes tucked away we found
it it's right there paragraph 15 of the
diversion agreement is the following
paragraph let me read it to you quote
the United States agrees not to
criminally prosecute Biden outside of
the terms of this agreement for any
federal crimes encompassed by the
attached statement of facts well the
statement of facts included details
about possible drug crimes gun crimes
tax crimes all related to multiple
sketchy international business deals you
know with China Ukraine Russia and about
a dozen other countries and all based on
a new batch plea agreement Hunter would
never ever face any consequences is for
any of these potential other crimes in
other words what were all these
countries paying somebody addicted to
crack four if not access to his vice
president and father now aside from the
two misdemeanor tax violations and the
Deferred gun charge can you imagine
someone associated with Donald Trump
ever getting a deal like that this is
what America needs to think about
tonight because this is now we're now
talking about our constitution the
foundation of which every law we have is
built on and in other words do we
believe we're a constitutional republic
or are we going to shred that document
that keeps Law and Order and Safety and
Security in our in our society uh
Merrick Garland are you proud of this
Christopher Ray are you proud Mr higher
honor James Comey signed three of the
fisa warrants when none of the
information you gave was verifiable it
says verified at the top of the warrant
you proud tonight under Garland
disgraceful partisan leadership the doj
has now gone from bad to worse any trust
in the department of justice has now
been shattered and yet Merrick Garland
he seems to care less doesn't seem to
care at all but let not your heart be
troubled of any charges against hunter
ever make their way through Garland's
partisan doj the White House Press
Secretary has assured us that Joe will
not offer Hunter a single pardon take a
look
I know you said Not A lot's changed
since yesterday and it's a personal
matter but from a presidential
perspective is there any possibility
that the president would end up
pardoning his son no
no I just said no I just answered go
ahead go ahead
just like when she's four that President
Biden had no involvement with his son's
business deals and when Joe said not one
time did I ever talk to my son or my
brother or anybody for that matter about
my about their foreign business dealings
not one time Joe Biden has no integrity
at all whatsoever look it's this simple
if we don't write the ship at the doj
and the FBI we don't remain a
constitutional republic the country will
be in deep deep trouble you can't have
one system of law for one group of
people and then have this entire Elite
group that don't get prosecuted the same
way as everybody else hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else